Hey Deadpool here, and this is what I look like on a pathetic regular screen
but hold on to your balloon knot, because on IMAX
I look twice as
What is this?
No, the screen is larger. So naturally I'd be larger too. Oh, that, great. That that's just great. I'm a child actor now
That always ends well
You see Deadpool in glorious
Larger-than-life IMAX because bigger is better.
Meet Domino. Now what's your schtick? I'm lucky. luck isn't the superpower.
Yes, it is. No, it's not
You underestimate my powers
Nice but not a superpower
Yes, it is
Let's meet in the middle and say no it isn't
You're hired
Lucky me
Hit it!
There's this kid, he's in trouble
Mover guy
Pump the hate breaks Thanos
I ain't lettin' cable get to him
We're gonna form a super duper group. It's time to get back on LinkedIn
Meet bad luck
Domino, I'm lucky
Luck isn't a superpower. Yes. It is. Let's meet in the middle and say no it isn't
Your bullets, they're really fast
And last but not least, Peter. Any power you wanna tell us about? You know, I don't have one
I just saw the ad. You're in
Get tickets now